[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le débrief
des questions au gouvernement de ce
mardi 21 avril des questions au
gouvernement toujours dans un format
réduit
mais avec davantage de députés que les
semaines précédentes dans l'hémicycle
tous les orateurs étaient présents avec
beaucoup de questions sur le décompte
finement qui se profile pour le 11 mai
prochain
si philippe vigier le président du
groupe liberté et territoires salue la
décision du gouvernement d'autoriser à
nouveau les visites dans les ehpad ils
demandent si d'autres professionnels de
santé comme les psychologues ou les
orthophonistes pourront eux aussi se
rendre à nouveau dans les ehpad
vous avez pris une bonne décision
dimanche soir en disant que dans les
ehpad et là où il ya billy seulement il
fallait rompre cet isolement
je vous demande monsieur le premier
ministre est de faire en sorte que les
kinésithérapeutes les orthophonistes et
hors top 6 les psychologues cus aussi
aller voir si personne
les syndromes du glissement sont devant
nous je vous en remercie c'est vrai du
contact familiale et ça doit être vrai
au fur et à mesure du temps des contacts
professionnels n'ont pas directement de
médecin parce que cela doive évidemment
et ont toujours continué mais de tous
ceux qui accompagnent les soignants qui
sont eux-mêmes soignants dans un certain
nombre de spécialités que vous avez
mentionné
nous devons le faire progressivement
avec des règles de sécurité évidemment
très stricte mais nous devons le faire
car vous avez raison les syndrome de
glissement se multiplient
le confinement dans une chambre
individuelle pour une personne
désorientée parfois frappées par la
maladie d'alzheimer parfois frappées par
d'autres pathologies
en tout état de cause en situation de
dépendance puisque c'est pour la raison
pour laquelle elle dans un ehpad conduit
assez largement à des syndromes de
glissements c'est vrai dans les
structures collectives
mais c'est vrai vous savez aussi à la
maison dans l'est dans les logements
dans les foyers ce syndrome nous
inquiète
il inquiète l'ensemble des
professionnels qui connaissent le
secteur il faut donc trouver les moyens
de garantir la sécurité sanitaire des
personnes les plus fragiles on ne les
condamnons pas l'isolément complet
voilà c'est une équation redoutable
monsieur le président mais nous devons
réussir à trouver les solutions qui
permettent de la résoudre
j'ai bon espoir qu'avec la mesure qui a
été prise s'agissant des ehpad et
qu'avec les mesures de solidarité qui
sont prises notamment par les communes
par les ccas qui font un travail
remarquable par les reprise de contact
entre les médecins ou les municipalités
avec les personnes âgées
ce lien c'est syndrome de glissement
puisse être dans toute la mesure du
possible éviter c'est l'enjeu qui est
devant nous c'est un enjeu de santé
publique du nhs entendu mais c'est plus
que certain enjeu d'humanité
quelles conditions pour un retour à
l'école le 11 mai prochain jean michel
blanquer a présenté ce mardi ses
hypothèses devant les députés
mais pour xavier breton député les
républicains de l'ain plusieurs zones
d'ombré subsistent
ce matin monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous avez annoncé
en commission un certain nombre
d'orientations notamment en termes de
calendrier
cependant de nombreuses questions
restent en suspens les interrogations
niveau sanitaire tout d'abord toutes les
conditions seront elles remplies pour
organiser l'accueil des élèves des
enseignants du personnel avec le maximum
de sécurité l'utilisation des masques
sera t'elle requise des tests seront ils
réaliser et si oui selon quelles
modalités
comment faire respecter les gestes
barrière à la distanciation sociale par
les élèves du primaire qui sont les
moins enclins à les pratiquer et qui
pourtant devrait rentrer les premiers je
vous le dis très clairement il y aura un
protocole sanitaire
il sera cohérent avec l'ensemble de la
doctrine sanitaire que le premier
ministre explicitera lorsqu il donnera
son plan pour l'ensemble du
déconfinement de la france est bien
entendu chacun des points que vous avez
10 internats cantines transport scolaire
aura été traitées fera l'objet d'un
écrit qui sera la condition sinequanone
pour que les élèves aillent à l'école au
collège ou au lycée
si ces conditions ne sont pas remplies
l'école où l'établissement n'ouvre pas
c'est très clair par ailleurs ce sera
progressif
ce sont les hypothèses que j'ai proposé
ce matin et qui permettent de comprendre
comment on peut imaginer des 2000 groupe
puisqu'il faut des petits groupes pour
respecter les règles de distanciation
social est donc bien entendu ces
hypothèses là aussi sont encore faites
pour être discutées mais me paraît
souhaitable que l'on commence par les
classes considérés comme des classes
charnières importante et puis qu'on
continue par la suite je les expliciter
ce matin mais je reste très ouvert à
toutes les propositions qui pourront
être faites pour améliorer encore le
dispositif tel que nous commençons à
l'envisager
le confinement aggrave les inégalités
sociales selon clémentine autain
réputé la france en soumises de
seine-saint-denis que faire alors pour
aider les plus démunis pour elle le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
les français font des économies pendant
la crise sanitaire d'autres toujours
plus nombreux font la queue pour obtenir
un repas peut-être avez-vous vu ses
longues files d'attentes à clichy sous
bois devant les restaurants
universitaires ou ailleurs on y découvre
un public jeune qui n'est pas habitué à
recourir à la solidarité pour manger
vous proposer pour le 15 mai une aide de
150 euros par foyer bénéficiaire du rsa
ou de la ss plus 100 euros par enfant à
charge
mais le 15 mai monsieur le premier
ministre c'est encore dans 72 repas
comment vont faire les familles dois je
vous rappeler que le coût du panier
moyen a bondi de 89 % au début du mois
moi je travaille depuis le début de la
crise avec les associations de l'aide
alimentaire
vous avez tenu à remercier les bénévoles
a remercié les élus locaux
je travaille au quotidien avec elle nous
les aidons notamment à tenir bon
parce que elles doivent maintenir leur
aide alimentaire à goâve parfois
rétablir l'aide alimentaire c'est tous
les enjeux que nous travaillons avec
gabriel atteint et la plate forme je
veux aider point gouv.fr quand elles ont
besoin de bénévoles pour pouvoir
distribuer pour pouvoir ouvrir des
distributions et des lieux distribution
de l'aide alimentaire auprès des
étudiants précarité au sein des
résidences universitaires et c'est bien
en travaillant tous ensemble qu'on
apporte une solution et dans quelques
dans quelques jours j'apporterai des
mesures très concrètes de financement à
ces associations et permettez moi aussi
de souligner le travail que porte julien
normandie avec les chèques services
avec ses 15 millions d'euros plus 5
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
arrive dès ce week-end pour financer les
chèques services à ces personnes qui
sont hébergés et qui de fait ne peuvent
pas faire à manger et qui vont pouvoir
par le biais ces chèques services à les
acheter à manger
je vous remercie les associations sont
elles aussi impactés par le coronavirus
et les conséquences du confinement
bruno myle yens député modem des
yvelines s'inquiètent du devenir des
subventions promises par le gouvernement
avant la crise monsieur le ministre les
chiffres tombent deux tiers des
associations sont à l'arrêt une étude
récente parle d'une perte de recettes
d'activité de près de 1,4 milliard
nous savons que leurs particularités
comptable que leur fragilité économique
font qu'elle rentre aujourd'hui moins
bien dans les cases prévues pour les
entreprises
est ce qu'un plan de sauvetage est en
cours est ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer que à l'image de ce qui se
fait dans de nombreuses collectivités
l'état à travers ses ministères et au
rendez-vous du versement des subventions
que je peux vous annoncer aujourd'hui
c'est que nous travaillons avec le
premier ministre à une circulaire
interministérielle qui sera publié dans
les prochains jours qui demandera à
l'ensemble des ministères d'honorer les
subventions quand bien même le projet
n'aurait pu avoir été mené je vous donne
des exemples solidarité sida qui ne peut
organiser le festival solidays recevra
quand même sa subvention de l'état qui
était prévu pour ce festival des
associations de protection de
l'environnement qui réalise
habituellement à cette période
le décompte des espèces qui devait
recevoir des subventions pour cela
recevront leurs subventions c'est un
signal très fort j'appelle évidemment
les collectivités locales et les
entreprises mécènes à suivre cette voie
parce que nous avons besoin des
associations en ce moment nous en aurons
besoin aussi
après ce confinement évidemment pour
reconstruire voilà pour le débris vis
des questions au gouvernement de ce 21
avril dès la semaine prochaine
75 députés seront présents à l'assemblée
nationale pour un retour à un format
plus classique des questions au
gouvernement
quant à nous on se retrouvera sur les
réseaux sociaux pour un nouveau débrief